[Music]
science which i love by the way
we love science too a lot of days people
like be like i don't believe in science
anymore or they throw around like check
your science that you throw that around
too oh check it
check your sign
so science is helping us understand at
last what it was like to [ __ ] a caveman
oh really
real [ __ ] science dude answering the
real questions and [ __ ] cornhub only
cavemen what about cave women i think
that's what they meant put on the hat
when you say that and they'll feel
better yeah which hat the joe biden one
oh okay now ask it thank you what about
cave and women that's tight man cave x
cave x uh yeah
uh yeah that's more on brand that's more
now i feel good about it so there are
there are thousands of mammalian bones
that were found inside of many caves
and uh over the over this long history
it has it has been thought that this
cave
was um
primarily inhabited by
male cavemen so it was a gay cave it was
a gay brothel
no it has to be a brothel not no
not male caveman male cave bears which
you know teeny up there
but actual actual brown bears right
relatives of brown bears not white polar
bears yeah but resting on the surface of
the of that
cave right
um because this is like these caves also
have water and like near the surface
there's also human jaw bones found damn
they ate the [ __ ] cavemen that could
be
and um they radiocarbonated these things
and revealed them to be one of the
oldest uh known modern humans in europe
how old they're still fighting these old
ass bones in europe they're still
finding them dude
those europeans suck at finding [ __ ] i
mean they've been around there so long
and they're still finding new stuff they
just never look for sure i understand
egypt because things can be covered in
sand and stuff but like come on dude
like how many caves does europe have
well they're already driving the wrong
side of the road how do you how long do
you think it takes that's true you know
why because the friendships are [ __ ]
lazy dude
the french the spanish that they're
always yeah yeah they're not doing
anything they complained about america
yeah wearing scarves and [ __ ] yo and
berets they're just sleeping all day and
[ __ ] dude it's taking many siestas and
surrendering all the time
almost exclusively oh yeah i don't even
know war that they won before napoleon
so part of part of what they found when
they were extracting dna from this fine
which was in 2015 from the java they
found the end of the this individual is
male
69 neanderthal which is the highest
concentration ever encountered in early
modern human and around three times the
amount found in present-day europeans in
asians whose genetic makeup is roughly
one to three percent due to just
dilution over the years right so this
dude got a lot of neanderthals six to
nine percent wow yeah which is 69 or six
to nine six to nine but if you put them
together at 69. hey
science and science really liked that
too yeah they loved it they're big fans
so because the genome contains large
stretches of uninterrupted neanderthal
sequences they calculated that the jaw's
owner is likely to have had a ancestor
as recently as four to six generations
ago so their like great grandpa was a
neanderthal it's like a great great
grandparent or a great great great
grandparent four generations right yeah
yeah great great great so what's their
[ __ ] style like so they say that they
did a doggy
in the ass mostly
they never write that like i would
actually really assume that doggy style
would have been the way to go default
would they call it doggy style at a time
before dogs were domesticated well man's
best friend might have come early how do
chimps do
do a mission mostly yeah they start with
eating their ass first and then they go
into it they do the foreplay they also
do they also do little frogs you see
that they jack off yeah yeah we pulled
it up here it's great you did
i think in that video joe wouldn't stop
saying fifi bag which
made me uncomfortable personally i had
to go to church after that's a fifi bag
so joe could not stop saying that so
amphibian fifi bag
hopefully he doesn't keep that tradition
alive in this video i'm hoping though
we'll see i hope for a lot of things
uh
so they're saying that you know they're
that they have
they believe that if you look at all of
this stuff and you put it all together
you can kind of tell a story with the
way that
like you know the genome has
moved throughout like a detective yeah
damn yeah
you could be like they started off
making out in this pile of fire right
here and then they slowly moved their
way over there and then that meant
talking
they slowly ripped off the pelts and
[ __ ] went for titties first turned on
some kenny g dude cleared the table of
all the spearheads
so they believe the first one axes and
[ __ ]
[ __ ] pottery so they believe that the
first the first [ __ ] occurred 120 000
years ago
because of the jawbone they could find
that out yeah because
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
an overbite over time look it's not even
plugged in
that's how the modern human job came to
be overbite and then that's how the new
blow job started happening good
old-fashioned sucking so the there's a
belief right due to all this and just to
really because this is a lot of data
right but but there's a belief that our
microbiome is working correctly today
because we picked up micro organisms
from neanderthals who were hoped who
were they believe kissing
at the time oh and that helped develop
microbiome yeah
help develop the microbiome and help
pass it along through generation from
kissing swap and spit yeah they were
[ __ ] making out back then they knew
what that [ __ ] was it was invented in
french then it wasn't invented in france
yeah they rebranded that [ __ ] this is
the french kiss right but we don't know
but we don't know they could have gone
oh it could have been like a peck now
they they were swapping you know they
were [ __ ] i think it was a tongue
it's had to be a little bit gross
monkeys kiss
they do all of it i see monkeys kiss
don't they do that in like the
domesticated ones and the zoos are
you know trapped yeah and i see them
kiss them that's at universal studios
but they don't like map each other down
right
cause they just go like it's just like
the orange like they have two orange
peels i don't think yeah i don't think
they're using their opposable thumb to
grab and face
i bet they are though i think i would
i'll give you some push back on that
anything i think they do back to the
doggy style i think they do
yeah so
they believe that that you know
neanderthals and early modern humans
would would be interbreeding a lot
obviously because
that's just who was around yep that's
just what happened back then yeah what
else you're gonna do and then the
neanderthal numbers started to dwindle
towards the end of their existence
because humans [ __ ] them out humans
kind of [ __ ] them out yep
and they broke their backs as well they
helped them out
they're saying some of the
some of the uh ethnicities that existed
in the past are not here today what's
that some of the ethnicities or groups
that like were around in the past or
like like define the past well like so
like ancient egyptians are not the same
as a current day egyptians or like even
with japan um ancient japanese dna is
not the same as like there was a time in
history where um like chinese dna or
like that area came okay mixed in with
the indigenous but i think this is
genghis khan genghis kham that's like
tootin cam and dude tootin camo was like
three foot tall oh three feet dude king
king two was like three foot tall
and he died at like age 13 because of
how much [ __ ] incest that went down
yeah but damn 100
i heard cleopatra had a was it both the
gender type the the pc word for
someone that has both genitals
gigantic titties though yeah because uh
back then they thought that that was a a
beauty
like having both like it's it's it's
rare nature stuff whatever right it's
like an air fryer do everything it's
like a firefighter you could do both you
could have a lot of fun they had air
fryers back then by the way scientists
can't figure out how i was just telling
you about air fries remember you did
very relevant we just went to the getty
villa
recently they had an air fryer [ __ ]
air fryer in the wall
egyptians actually the egyptian section
i was like yo they have air fryers here
yeah they found a 30 000 year old air
fryer
that's some ancient alien [ __ ] dude and
had a steel tray bin and everything yeah
just got to put it in the right angle of
the sun and the sun will do the work
they had to light the fire in the bottom
and still had the price tag from sears
says black and decker
that's a very old brand yeah wow it was
one of the exhibits it was a main
exhibit
everyone loved it yo
well what did you do at the gated museum
no i just went to go check it out and
then check out your fries see if there
was an air fryer i went to go shopping i
want to see what air fryer is you know
what though like um when you see ancient
[ __ ] at a museum versus a pawn shop or
like where you can actually there's a
price tag to it it changes like an art
gallery where there's a [ __ ] ancient
rug and you're like damn it's just
[ __ ] 300 000 dollars when i'm at a
museum i'm like
damn that's old
right but then like because of value
yeah you know but you don't go like that
you don't go like
one day
no i don't feel like can we put a price
tag on this [ __ ] like what's up dude
cause we tell everybody yeah i wanna i
actually want that so i could be like i
can own this one day and then i can
leave it in my house
and then it'll appreciate you know what
i mean like like how mr winn right here
he has he's the largest private
collector of [ __ ] classical art some
of those things in museums are owned by
people they're just leasing it to the
museum yeah see my broadcast didn't even
know that dude they're leasing it to
them yeah they're like crazy i'm sure
there's a price if you inquire you know
you just go you can let them borrow it
so that means you're [ __ ] making rent
on the 300 000 rug we gotta get some
artifacts yo and lisa king tut was two
foot seven
foot seven that's like hot
dog yeah you little bro
are you serious can you tell us husband
nah but king tut was two foot six inches
in and a half so like they don't even
make a dyson that's short in 700 bc like
the like the the romans and [ __ ] their
helmets were like this [ __ ] big they
were like tiny little i swear to god man
helmets dude that's crazy because they
kept running the shades they're all
stupid what if those are cups no no it
was a [ __ ] helmet it said helmet and
then like a chest piece was like it
wasn't that big at all
the war museum in france when you look
at like uh napoleon's they were like 11
year olds they look like this yeah but
napoleon was notorious for how small he
was no but his soldiers like all the
armors yeah it was all like this that's
what i got i thought they were child
soldiers
they could be oh maybe i don't know no
but they're petite they were small
though
[Laughter]
that's how they put all their armor on
too
walk through the [ __ ] wall yeah just
from hook yeah
oh [ __ ] i had that wrong no because i
was looking at centimeters king [ __ ]
king tut was two foot two
shut the [ __ ] up
it keeps getting smaller and two foot
two hey we would kick the [ __ ] out of
king tut no two feet is like this
he was two foot two inches so he was
like bro
humans evolved dog they evolved to be
bigger that's crazy dude tyka's [ __ ]
42 inches dude look at quizno that's
impossible and taco would kick the [ __ ]
out of king tut and cuz nine years
younger you're a double leg
back then that's how they should they
need to market it you want the king tut
size like that's how he had a gold
coffee because it was [ __ ] tight he's
like one foot eight that's taller than a
fat tuesday bro
because they had him in there like this
tuesday from king tooth the sarcophagus
is whatever they were like they weren't
that big they were like this that was
like this size
i've seen dicks bigger than that yo wait
what
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you